bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur les
plateformes du figaro c'est l'heure du
débat c'est l'heure de vos points de vue
et ce soir ce divan rioufol bonsoir yvan
essayiste et chroniqueur au figaro
votre chronique à paraître dans
l'édition papier de ce vendredi ces
réalités qu'on ne peut plus cacher c'est
bien ça face à vous lucile schmid
cofondatrice de la fabrique écologique
et ancien élu à la fois europe écologie
et ps et auteur d'un livre très
intéressant sur l'écologie on va y
revenir d'ailleurs ce soir avec en débat
les 100 milliards de jean castex un plan
de relance historique selon le premier
ministre il y en a pour l'écologie il y
en a pour l'emploi il y en a pour la
souveraineté alors s'appeler ça plaît à
beaucoup de monde s'appelait presque à
tout le monde mais est ce que ça peu
est-ce que ça va marcher
on en débat l'autre débat de la soirée
c'est sur une mesure qui est entrée en
vigueur mardi dernier l'amande de 200
euros pour consommation de drogue vous
parait-elle dissuasive
c'est la question qu'on vous pose sur le
site du figaro et c'est la question
qu'on vous pose ce soir alors la
première question quand même qu'on pose
elle est sur twitter êtes vous
convaincus par le plan de relance
présenté par jean castex dans questions
vous pouvez retrouver sur twitter et
bien sûr je vous invite à répondre par
oui pas répondre par non mais en tous
les cas à répondre et à débattre avec
nous beaucoup d'économistes et
personnalités politiques depuis ce matin
ont salué ce plan parmi les mesures
phares il ya d'abord et avant tout
l'emploi 100 milliards de richesse
nationale perdue c'est un taux de
chômage qui explose chômage bien sûr il
est dans les entreprises mais ça
concerne les français et les françaises
donc ce que nous voulons faire c'est
réinjecter massivement de l'argent dans
l'économie pour que l'économie et les
entreprises
bien sûr repartent si les entreprises
repartent ya moins de chômage il ya plus
emploi c'est aussi simple que cela
essai détaillé dans l'interview
exclusive
que le fig pas exclusive mais la
première en tous les cas que le premier
ministre a accordé c'était au figaro et
donc c'est à retrouver sur le site du
figaro l'autre mesure phare c'est la
transition l'aide à la transition
écologique france relance est d'abord un
plan destiné à servir le climat et la
biodiversité
il consacre 30 milliards à cette
transition
ce qui revient à plus que doubler
mesdames et messieurs dans les deux
prochaines années les investissements
que l'état consacre habituellement à
l'environnement alors même qu'ils
étaient déjà en forte progression le
s'il suit la ministre de la transition
écologique barbara pompili salue un pas
de géant l'écologiste vous êtes doit
être ravi non moi je pense que c'est
très important que les laits milliard
consacré à l'écologie dans le plan soit
passé de 20 à 30 et que maintenant le
premier ministre on fasse une priorité
c'est un changement symbolique pour
autant olic bassin changement symbolique
et les symboles comptent en politique
mon cher vincent c'est à dire que il est
essentiel qu'un premier ministre dont on
nous dit qu'il n'était pas du tout
familier la chose écologique aujourd'hui
pense que c'est une priorité en terme
d'affichage et ça signifie bien qu'il a
compris qui est un changement culturel
qui est en oeuvre après il ya la
question des modalités pratiques et il
ya donc l'enjeu de savoir si réellement
les choses vont permettre à transformer
à verdir l'économie comme comme on le
dit par ailleurs c'est comme vous le
savez sur fond de polémique assez
importante sur la question de
l'utilisation des néonicotinoïdes c'est
à dire la façon dont on va remettre
un pesticide qui est anti abeilles donc
il ya on voit qu'il ya un débat on peut
dire que c'est symbolique aussi le débat
sur les néonicotinoïdes on voit que sur
la question écologique
il ya un débat de société en cours il ya
des priorités politiques à établir et à
assumer et à la façon dont les milliards
sont utilisés parce que ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce plan de relance qui
est massif mon 100 milliards il a et
sépare de façon un peu artificielle
trois priorités et on voit on va
entendre sur les autres priorités mais
sur la question là écologique
le salut mathieu qui vient de rejoindre
et sur la question écologique vous
justement qui militante écologiste est
ce que au sens large est ce que vous
êtes satisfaite est ce que vous partagez
l'entousiasme par exemple de la ministre
pompidou
j'observe que la miss pompili selon les
jours elle est enthousiaste où elle est
forte ennuyer d'être au gouvernement
donc je partage l'optimisme
parce que à mon sens l'écologie ne peut
pas toujours se réfugier dans le fait de
dire il aurait fallu faire toujours
mieux
il ya un sujet de compromis il ya un
sujet de principe de réalité on ne
change pas les choses en un coup de
baguette magique sur l'écologie mais
j'observe aussi que barbara pompili a
été très attaquées ces derniers jours
sur le fait qu'elle avait promis des
choses je reviens sur les
néonicotinoïdes et qu'elle fait l
inverse
trois ans après donc toute la question
c'est comment est-ce que les shows
tiendront dans la durée et l'écologie
c'est de la ténacité il s'agit de
transformer le système est un plan de
relance c'est d'abord ça a été dit par
jean castex du court terme des rustines
comment est ce qu'on fait pour empêcher
le chômage
donc c'est un enjeu de temporalité et
c'est un enjeu qui va au delà de
l'affichage
même si encore une fois ci jean castex
l'annoncent c'est sans doute qu'il a
compris que c'était un enjeu électoral
c'était un enjeu électoral il vend c'est
votre analyse c'est juste qu'ils font ça
pour un hors jeu électoral ou bien
est-ce que vous a plu prouver plus
largement cette mesure en faveur de la
transition écologique
rien qui contient notamment 2 milliards
pour le développement de l'hydrogène à
milliard un milliard deux pour
l'agriculture où je n'ai rien contre eux
on voit bien qu'il ya une démarche
électorale nature longue c'est un sujet
qui est devenu un sujet d'actualité
c'est un sujet d'ailleurs qui mobilise
ce très très ardemment tous que la
technocratie peu qu'on ne peut avoir de
compétences parce que le gouvernement
est là dans son propre domaine c'est à
dire que il a fait l'analyse que les
crises étaient économique social
sanitaire et écologique au réchauffement
climatique etc
là dessus il est il est tout à fait
parfait il va il va lancer des feux
d'artifice tous les étages sans voir que
la crise de mon point de vue n'est pas
celle ci enfin elle est naturellement
économique social et peut-être
écologique mais elle est d'abord
sécuritaires et identitaires or ces deux
crises la sont évacués et à chaque fois
on revoit à coups de superlatifs sur les
amplis grande avancée historique n'est
pas l'on sert des 100 milliards je suis
incapable je ne suis pas expert
économique je ne sais pas quand
j'entends 100 milliards jeudi qui paye
d'où vient d'où vient cet argent qu
est-ce que ce qu'est ce que sont ces
billets de mines de monopoly rien n'est
plus simple que de faire une pluie de
mes 2 milliards naturellement et mais
moi ce que je vois je vois un paradoxe
là dedans c'est à dire que la crise du
coc vie de mon point de vue a montré une
chose c'est que l'état jacobin à l'état
centralisateur l'état et technocratique
l'état qui s'est tous ne savait rien en
tout cas de pour gérer une crise face à
un virus et il est paradoxal de voir
qu'aujourd'hui il relance des plans des
plans des plans des plans on en voit
partout alors même que c'est précisément
ce sont ces plans là qui ne servent à
rien ou en tout cas qui sont déficientes
donc il me semble qu'il ya un manque de
de diagnostic sur les grandes mutations
de la société
on a l'air de croire que la france de
l'après guerre serait semblable à celle
d'aujourd'hui on voit qu'on l'en confie
un haut commissariat au plan à françois
bayrou en ressortant les des viviers
chose de 1946 qui avait d'ailleurs été
auparavant tester leurs hymnes et sayah
au plan a pas de jouer robert ou non de
fermer cette base non non non non non
mais donc on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas
d'imagination et dont on refait on
ressort les
les techniques les vieux réflexes
technocratique et jean castex
on est vraiment le web et c'est un bol
regardez si je puis dire mais je ne suis
pas sûr et je suis même certain dans
fait du contraire que je ne suis pas sûr
que ce discours là soit le discours qui
correspondent exactement aux réalités de
la france ce que dit yvan rioufol est
est intéressant sur cette question de la
réalité sociale et le devoir d'
imagination politique et sur l'écologie
j'avais envie de dire en écoutant jean
castex et 10 c le plan du climat et de
la biodiversité il hésite un peu plus
dit il faut toujours dire ça il ya
toujours ces deux expressions à la fois
et on voit bien que au fond là dans ce
plan de relance c'est la transformation
de l'économie verte est évidemment
l'écologie mais je veux pas apparaître
comme un esprit chagrin
l'écologie n'est pas réductible à la
transformation économique et je pensais
à ça par rapport à l'eau il a dit ce
qu'il a dit à la transformation
économique c'est à dire que l'écologie
est un moteur de transformation
économique sur le bâtiment sur la
voiture sur les transports ça permet de
faire des têtes à queue sur le train par
exemple de remettre les trains de nuit
et les petites lignes qu'on avait voulu
supprimer l'année dernière c'est
intéressant l'écologie ça permet les
tête-à-queue et ça permet de relancer la
dépense publique mais il ya quelque
chose qui n'est pas dit par exemple
c'est que l'écologie c'est donner à la
nature une place essentielle dans notre
vie dans notre manière de penser et il
n'y a rien à voir là dedans avec sedan
ce plan c'est peut-être normal que c'est
parce que c'est un plan de relance mais
si la pensée du gouvernement doit
changer elle doit aussi intégrer cette
question de la nature par exemple on
refait pas des autoroutes
parce que dans ce cas là il ya un sujet
sur la forêt il ya quelque chose qui
dérangera profondément le raisonnement
pour aux vendeurs sur ce que dit lucile
pensez pas quand même yvan que justement
le problème la transition écologique ou
en tout cas la question climatique
puisque le premier ministre l'a souligné
dans son intervention ce midi font
partie justement des grandes mutations
et des grandes problématiques
d'aujourd'hui les blondasses et doit se
développer nous faire croire que
l'urgence se réduire et à l'urgence
climatique je veux bien admettre que
naturellement il ya un réchauffement
climatique mais entendu mais ce n'est
pas pour moi l'urgence immédiate
l'urgence immédiate en tout cas si je me
mets à la place des français si je crois
comprendre les inquiétudes de 2 de ceux
qui habitent qui habite avant ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas tant cette urgence
climatique là que l'urgence d'abord
l'urgence économique pour ceux qui sont
au chômage et qu'il était armé mais
surtout l'urgence sécuritaire l'urgence
identitaire l'urgence civilisationnel on
voit que tous les sondages montrent
aujourd'hui que tous ceux qui avaient
décrit ces deux france qui s'éclatait
les engagements qu en effet des contres
société se forme et ne vivent plus
ensemble ne veulent plus vivre ensemble
ne partage plus les mêmes les mêmes
règles moi ceci me paraît beaucoup plus
essentiels à régler que d'avoir à
s'intéresser naturellement à flatter un
électeur inverse qui est un électorat
qui en plus politiquement des prêts à
trahir les vraies causes écologiques moi
je suis écologiste comme qui qui peut
être contre l'écologie franchement mais
quand je vois la politisation de ligue 2
ce qui représente les verts aujourd'hui
je me dis ce qui dans le fond qui rend
notre mauvais service à cette écologie
en cautionnant à travers elle tout un
chambre tout un bouleversement politique
sur la manière de concevoir la
démocratie libérale de manière de
concevoir le capitalisme du col le libre
échange
enfin tout ce qui était également
fondamental et il me semble que
l'analyse ci on compte devrait faire et
de se rendre compte à travers par
exemple ce que l'on a pu voir n'ont pas
dû qu'au vu de méduse gilet jaune qu' il
y à une appétence aujourd'hui plutôt non
pas pour un centralisme étatique mais au
contraire pour des décentralisations du
giron du local du g et il ya une sorte
de
l'écologie de tous les jours si je puis
dire ce qui est intéressant dans ce que
dit yvan rioufol c'est que moi je
repense à ce qu'avait dit nicolas hulot
sur fin du monde des fins de mois c'est
à dire que la vérité c'est que chacun
d'entre nous se sont assaillis par
toutes ces urgences à la fois et que
tout l'enjeu c'est de savoir exactement
qui comment est-ce qu'on traite les
urgences le comment et qui et comment
est-ce qu'on travaille ensemble c'est à
dire que évidemment c'est pas un plan de
relance qu'il tombe du ciel qui va
modifier profondément la question
sociale qui va modifier profondément
l'urgence écologique et tout l'enjeu au
fond sur ce plan de relance c'est
comment est ce qu'il va être 6 pour
qu'ils soient pas la pluie de milliards
dont on vient de parler et auquel vous
avez raison de dire que personne ne
croit c'est à dire que vous savez depuis
le confinement vit soudé puis 2
milliards successives c'est à dire qu'il
ya les pluies de milliards européenne là
il y aura d'ailleurs 40 milliards qui
vont venir de l'union européenne et on
ne peut pas ne pas saluer ses efforts
mais qui comptera n'y mettons en jeu
s'est passé alors tu ne sens pas encore
qui ne font pas qu'en fin qui ne sont
pas acquittés parce que le parlement
européen au moment de la pente et mais
en tout cas il y a l'idée qui aura une
imbrication entre plan de relance
européen et plan de relance français
mais tout l'enjeu c'est comment est-ce
qu'on passe ensuite proposé un terme
technocratique au micro économique et
surtout comment chaque individu chaque
personne et au sein la société ressent
le fait que le plan existe vraiment en
dehors de l'interview exclusive dans le
figaro donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel et ça ne s'est jamais
produit avec aucun plan de relance ça
paraît très très ambitieux de proclamer
que ce plan placera la france leader des
nouvelles technologies nous dit mathieu
lui qui connaît bien le secteur
ats ce secteur à taïwan en corée du sud
au japon et on est très à la traîne
selon lui donc ça prouve quand même là
encore une fois ils vont agir bien
est-ce que ça justifie pas l'opportunité
quand même d'avoir
d'avoir mis un petit peu d'avoir mis de
l'argent sur la table pour pouvoir en
tout cas investir et préparer la france
je dis pas expert en économie donc je ne
pourrais pas me n'aurais pas la
prétention de dire que ce plan est bon
ou non est mauvais je vois bien que ce
plan est bon en tout cas pour aig pour
sur l'opportunité en partie des porcs
une partition de ces décisions c'est
qu'il va permettre aujourd'hui aux
entrepreneurs au vue de l'allègement de
leur impôt sur les investissements 20
milliards d'impôts d'allègements
d'impôts c'est vrai mais normes de
d'envisager en effet de rapatrier toutes
ces industries qui avait dû aller à
l'étranger parce que là bas les charges
sociales le coût du travail était
moindre
je pense que ça c'est une très bonne
mesure une mesure très intelligente que
de que d'inciter aujourd'hui les
entrepreneurs à revenir produire de la
richesse en france afin et en leur
promettant de paix qu'ils paieront moins
d'impôts et 10 20 milliards en deux ans
de suppression d'impôt parce que ce qui
est annoncé
ça c'est un parent est formidable donc
là dessus je voulais dire une chose je
cautionne pour le reste je sur l'europe
sur leur localisation sur la
relocalisation moi je comprends la
volonté affichée après on a vu ce qui
s'est passé avec lubrizol on voit les
inquiétudes sur tous les sites seveso en
france et donc la relocalisation
industrielle adossée un pays qui est de
plus en plus vers en tout cas où le
changement culturel étant est en marche
ça suppose une vraie réflexion sur
l'aménagement du territoire et ça je
pense que c'est un enjeu très important
c'est à dire comment on doit remettre
les escomptes l'écologie freine la
réindustrialisation parce que là encore
ce nom mais des dramatiques ajouté je ne
l'oublions pas non mais n'oublions pas
si la france n'est qu'un pur sang j'ai
déjà dit que ça allait freiner mais je
pense que la question de l'aménagement
du territoire adossé à l'écologie ça
implique de réfléchir à des
relocalisations industrielles
différemment de ce qu'on aurait fait
dans les années 50 ou 60 vous avez dit
d'ailleurs on est peut-être plus dans la
même en société
voilà c'est tout il s'agit pas de
freiner et sans doute de veiller à des
spécialisations qui corresponde à ce
goût du verdissement de l'économie
je voulais revenir parce que ça
m'importe sur ce que vous avez dit sur
le haut commissariat au plan
moi je pense que ce qui est très
intéressant c'est comment on annonce à
la fois le plan de relance et la
création de ce haut commissariat au plan
qui ne sera pas la chose de françois
bayrou c'est à dire que c'est une
structure qui est recréée
dont je rappelle qu'elle avait été
supprimée il se trouve que j'ai
travaillé un moment elle avait été
supprimée dans les années 2000 elle
avait été renommée supprimés et
maintenant on avait une stratégie voix
et pourquoi est ce que c'est important
parce qu'on voit bien qu'au milieu de
toutes ces urgences pour s'y retrouver
la question d'un lieu de dialogue entre
les différents acteurs les différentes
parties les acteurs territoriaux les
syndicats les universitaires ceux qui
ont une vision et la possibilité ensuite
de mettre un cap
moi ça me semble important après tout
dépend de la manière dont on va donc ce
qui est important c'est de réfléchir en
effet aux mutations de la société mais
je ne pense pas que ce soit sous
françois bayrou lui-même qui est porte
un regard à regarder à venir sur ce
qu'est la société dans la mesure où je
les ai vus souvent s'aveugler sur ce
qu'était cette société là et donc je ne
suis pas sûr qu'un rassemblement de
d'experts ou de technocrates puis ceux
indiqués très précisément quels sont les
leviers pour la france donne est
d'accord et l'autre et d'autre part le
haut commissariat au plan pouvait encore
s'imaginer après guerre dans un pays
souverain
mais quand le pays ne maîtrise plus la
grande majorité de ces décisions de
faire un plan dans un pays encore malgré
tout vert à une mondialisation qu'on a
désiré ça me paraît tout à fait
aléatoire et donc je n'y crois pas du
tout et donc je vois beaucoup
d'agitation l'agitation de billets de
banque d'agitation de grands programmes
christory elle découvre que l'état peut
finalement dépassé dépenser des
milliards sans conséquences et il ya une
autre question peut-être julius qui nous
dit qu est il arrivé à ce gouvernement
libéral il ne fait plus couvrir les
vannes de la dépense publique
aujourd'hui c'est le grand paradoxe en
effet 6 et ce n'est pas un gouvernement
libéral
là il c'était une étatisation à tous les
étages déjà durant le coc vide j'avais
lu une étude qui montrait que les trois
quarts des salaires avaient été payés
avaient été payés par l'état
c'est-à-dire fonctionnaires retraités
chômeurs chômeurs partiels et cetera les
trois quarts des salaires des français
avait été publiée par l'état donc même
en union soviétique je suis pas sûr
qu'ils le corps mais il faut réussir que
les salaires ne soient pas payés je
pensais que mon style je constate je
constate ceci c'est donc on est là et on
a rompu avec le
l'idée libérale parce que l'idée
libérale n'aurait pas peur mais on avait
une situation exceptionnelle et c'est
sûr je suis moi je conseille cette
liaison gare à lui aurait permis de
faire confiance aux gens et de ne pas
imposer ce set une fois un autre débat
oui seigneur et aux échecs étouffoir
mais peut-être que vous pouvez répondre
de lucile christophe qui nous dit des
américains n'ont pas besoin d'un rock
commissariat pour créer amazon apple ou
google
absolument je ne pense pas que la
prospective la pensée du futur se
réduisent a créé google et amazon donc
moi j'espère un monde où c'est pas mal
non mais pourquoi pas enfin si les
entreprises ont de l'éthique par
ailleurs et le l'enjeu de plans du
commissariat au plan c'est peut-être pas
la bonne appellation d on a repris la
vieille appellation c'est non pas de
faire un plan mais d'organiser un
dialogue entre l'ensemble des acteurs
notamment des entrepreneurs puisqu'on en
parle beaucoup sur ce plateau des
acteurs des mères moi je pense qu'il ya
eu directement je vous dis stuff encore
ceux qui vous répond ah oui ma vie à un
haut-commissariat gérés par des
administratifs avec la sécurité de
l'emploi qui n'ont jamais mis les pieds
dans une
est-ce que c'est pas ça ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on voit mais l'élection souvent
mais je pense que ça c'est redoutable et
que c'est absolument pas comme ça que
moi je verrai ce haut commissariat au
plan
alors je disais si le mot symboliquement
est mauvais ou si le fait d'imaginer que
des hauts fonctionnaires à l'abri de
murs qui ne connaissent pas le monde
c'est mauvais mais c'est pas ça du tout
le projet le projet c'est une
institution qui permet d'avoir un cap et
qui est ouverte sur le monde et qui à
mon sens ce dialogue avec d'autres
institutions comparables dans des pays
éventuellement comme les états unis
moi je préfère avoir emmanuel macron
comme président que donald trump mais on
peut ne pas être d'accord avec
christophe non mais c'est le problème
c'est de savoir si vraiment l'état a la
prétention d'être l'état visionnaire
alors même qu'ils ne voient rien de tout
de tout ce qui lui est classé la figure
et moi j'ai un doute sur sur l'île et
pas si c'est nous c'est à dire l'état ne
nous paraît pas sinon l'état c'est pas
nous l'état l'état exclut beaucoup de
précisément de ce2 qui participent qui
devrait participer à ce que vous votez
j'ai bien aimé chez l etat et c'est bien
le problème d'ailleurs de cette grande
fracture entre les élites qui prétendent
nous gouverner savoir si exactement ce
que l'on veut et le reste de la semaine
sur 3 et linn de l'orge et jose 5 ce
haut commissariat au plan pour honorable
parler de ça on pourrait parler d'autre
chose est vraiment le symbole très
exactement de ce que la société rejette
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'elle ne veut
plus de ceux de ce pouvoir centralisé
hiérarchie qu'elle veut
rusal participatif et surtout pas des
plans qu'ils soient imposées d'en haut
commissariat ne devra pas être du tout
ce que vous craignez nice que ce que
craint christophe gans mondial moi je
grande d'imagination dans le noyau a
relevé que je crois à l'imagination dans
l'enfer de l'état et dans la société
alors vous voyez à l'imagination au
pouvoir êtes vous convaincu par le plan
de relance présenté par le gouvernement
alors c'était la question composé sur
twitter ceux qui sont exprimés vous qui
vous êtes exprimés en vue qu'à vous êtes
plutôt sceptique
vous répondez non à 64% alors ça c'est
sur twitter et on vous poser une autre
question cette fois-ci sur le site du
figaro et là aussi je pense que la
réponse est négative mais en tous les
cas jouglar pause si vous n'avez pas
voté vous pouvez et avant de voter même
écouter justement le débat autour de
cette amende de 200 euros pour
consommation de drogue est ce qu elle
vous paraît dissuasif question qu'on me
pose donc sur le site du figaro demain
en fait dans l'édition papier du figaro
il y aura un dossier spécial sur cette
question sur cette mesure notamment
entrer en vigueur cette semaine et
défendu mordicus par le ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est à dire que le trafic doit aller en
prison ma d'années que le consommateur
doit d'être effectivement une sanction
et cette option c'est une amende
importante qui sera remise par les
forces de l'ordre lorsque vous aurez une
raie de shit sur vous un gramme de
cocaïne et chacun désormais doit être
responsabilisés et à partir du 1er
septembre
tout consommateur qui sera pris avec
du cannabis ou avec de cocaïne connaîtra
cette amende
le divorce n'est ce pas une bonne mesure
quand même dans le cadre de la politique
de tolérance zéro en tous les cas
voulues et affichées par le gouvernement
deux d'adopter cette mesure il faudrait
d'abord regarder comment cela se passait
dans la réalité pour l'instant et puis
voir quand même aussi un échantillon
7/10 l'important n'est pas une peine
dans une peine c'est pas une sévérité
mais sa certitude
oui le l'objectif c'est de faire en
sorte que ces gens-là n'aillent plus en
prison mais déjà il n'allait pas
beaucoup en prison donc c'était pour
éviter que toutes ces processus pour
désengorger le processus judiciaire
maintenant vous voyez très belle et très
bien comment ça se passe en général que
quand vous avez d une partie de la
population ne payera pas c est qu on
sait c contre ces contraventions enfin
ccpv donc mais parce que on peut
l'imaginer
on peut imaginer dans une partie de la
société en tout cas la société la plus
rebelle en tout cas dans tout dans toute
cette contre société qui trafiquent
beaucoup je peux parler de cul de ces
sites et ces 200 dons par kiki
maintenant ce sont devenus telle sorte
de ghetto avec des économies parallèles
et des oulad ou la drogue d'ailleurs est
le facteur presque essentiel du fait que
le calme depuis six ans story vous vous
coupez les vous couper les financements
de la drogue est immédiatement vous avez
à nouveau les les tensions qui peuvent
réapparaître et donc je n'imagine pas
que cette population là puissent se
plier aux injonctions d'une de policiers
d'abord qui est qui qui rend concert
constaterait une infraction et qui
ensuite seraient seraient d'accord pour
la payer donc m'enfin bon en même temps
je n'en sais rien c'est mais je pense
que tout ça n'est pas n'est pas le
problème n'est pas résolu le problème
des papes au n'est pas bien posé à tracy
on veut sanctionner les consommateurs ce
qui relance qui saute aux yeux c'est
qu'il faut sanctionner les trafiquants
et la trace du sanctionner les
sanctionner les trafiquants c'est ce
serait ouvrir une guerre un monde
parallèle qui est un monde terriblement
puissant qui tient encore une fois une
partie des banlieues s'il faut bien se
mettre ça dans la tête et je ne vois pas
que le gouvernement pourrait même émis
l'idée dans le fond d'avoir à démanteler
tous ces trafics la leucine sur
l'utilité de
dur je pense que c'est une mesure qui je
regardais et je voyais que gérard
collomb l'avait annoncé quand il était
ministre de l'intérieur donc c'est une
mesure qui était prévu par le
gouvernement d'assez longue date
je pense que c'est une mesure qui a été
prise au départ plutôt pour satisfaire
les policiers qui comme l'a dit yvan
rioufol n'en pouvais plus d'une
procédure inadaptée qui se traduisait
juste par des rappels à la loi
sachant que la france est l'un des pays
où le pays d'europe qu'à la législation
la plus restrictive et la plus par
rapport à la question des drogues mais
que le principe de réalité fait que
cette législation en fait n'entre jamais
dans la réalité c'est à dire que grosso
modo il ya que des rappels à la loi et
c'est extrêmement déprimant pour les
policiers qui arrêtent des dealers à des
consommateurs etc
j'aurais quand même aussi prendre un peu
de hauteur et vous rappeler que nathalie
kosciusko morizet qui n'est pas du tout
une gauchiste avait en son temps
promu la dépénalisation du cannabis et
que cet enjeu régulièrement évoqué
lorsqu'il s'agit de débats électoraux
nationaux est aussi un sujet débattu au
niveau européen qu'il ya une grande
diversité de pratiques là dessus en
belgique par exemple c'est le cas et
donc dans cette situation présente et ça
comme une mesure de zéro tolérance etc
alors qu'en fait comme l'a dit yvan
grosso modo c'est une mesure pour faire
moins de procédures mais on se doute
bien que les allemands ne seront pas
payés
il ya eu d'ailleurs des expérimentations
je regardais des expérimentations dans
trois villes et dans certains cas ça
assez bien fonctionné sur le fait que
les amendes soient payés parce qu'il y
avait eu un choix notamment du procureur
de se concentrer uniquement sur le
cannabis mais pas sur la cocaïne donc
sur les petits consommateurs mais ça ne
veut rien dire sur le fait que lorsqu on
généralise l'amande
elle sera vraiment payé parce que là y
aura elle sera très grande échelle
et effectivement ça laisse le trafic se
dérouler tranquillement et c'est un
trafic international avec des réseaux
très organisés sur lesquels il faudrait
mettre tous les moyens de la police et
des moyens différents de ceux des agents
qui arrête les consommateurs donc moi je
suis contre l'idée de sanctionner le
consommateur en tout cas dans
l'affichage alors qu'en fait grosso modo
ça va rien changer et je voudrais aussi
dire qu'on vient de vivre un événement
quand même extrêmement intéressant à
grenoble je voudrais en parler de ça on
va pas être grenoble juste d'être agir à
ce que disent les internautes puissent
vous continuez à réagir alors à la fois
sur le site du figaro est à la fois sur
le compte youtube du figaro où vous on
est content de vous retrouver de vous
trouver et de vous retrouver christophe
nous dit encore lui je crains que la
demande ne soit paix ne soient pas payés
par les insolvable comme les peines de
prison de moins de deux ans ne sont pas
exécutées sur twitter également on
pouvait lire cette objection
personnellement l'amande permet au co
perd la morne permet aux consommateurs
de bien comprendre qu'on ne risque plus
de prison pour fumer un joint
ça soulage les consommateurs et se faire
prendre en train de fumer sauf à fumer
le cannabis dans la rue est tellement
rare que le risque est très faible
donc ça c'est là une des objections et
tout le monde sait que peu importe le
prix il attend jamais les fumeurs car
ils sont bien trop à avoir une
consommation régulière ou même
récréative
c'est peut-être ça qui est un peu aussi
inquiétant non vous suggérez la
dépénalisation du cannabis c'est ce que
c'est ce que vous plaît moi je pense
qu'il faut il faut ils vont peut-être on
peut tout à fait y réfléchir il ya eu
d'autres et qu'ils ont fait je crois que
ce serait une mauvaise idée parce qu'en
fait d'abord il ya une propension à
alimenter quand même un instant je
pensais que vous étiez pour raisons
sanitaires
c'est à dire le le débat s'est ouvert il
est lancé il est il et il a été posé
dans d'autres pays européens qui
d'ailleurs ont parfois choisi cette
cette solution-là nombreux jeunes mais
je ne braque pas là dessus mais
simplement je constate que le l'économie
encore une fois l'économie souterraine
de
des cités n'est pas simplement
construite sur le trafic de la machine
je suis pas des drogues plus vite -
moins dure que
elle est construite sur des circuits
alternatifs si vous voulez si vous
autorisez l'inconscient belval le libre
commerce du cannabis
vous voulez vous inciterez ces
trafiquants a trafiqué d'autres choses
d'autres davantage d'autres drogues peut
être plus dur encore quelqu'un que je ne
suis pas un spécialiste de la drogue ou
des trafics d'armes ou de ceci ou de
cela je pense qu'il faut il faut bien
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui il me semble
que l'économie est elle aujourd'hui il
est tellement l'économie parallèle de
ces cités étaient aujourd'hui qu'elles
ne peuvent pas ne pas s'employer à
trouver d'autres filières alternatives
s'il part par votre proposition par
exemple il advenait que le cannabis soit
soir en vente libre je pense que ça ne
l'effraie pas beaucoup mais que c'est
dur
il aurait pas de manque à gagner pour
eux d'accord non ce que je trouve
important et ça a été dit en début de
débat c'est que cette amende
quand on lisait l'histoire d'amendé 200
euros quand on n'était pas spécialiste
du débat sur les drogues ont tissé mais
qu'est ce qui se passe je comprends pas
donc en tout cas il n'y a pas de
réflexion d'ensemble sur la politique
française à l'égard des drogues
je rappelle que depuis un an et demi
deux ans il ya en plus maintenant des
boutiques qui ont ouvertes sur qu'avec
le cbd comme on dit c'est à dire que ce
n'est pas le cannabis c'est un de
cannabis thérapeutique et que du coup il
ya même aujourd'hui des débats sur la
législation européenne qui ne coïncide
pas avec législation française est donc
un sentiment de grande confusion
en tout cas pour ceux qui ne sont pas
trafiquant que peut-être les
consommateurs ne comprennent pas eux
mêmes et donc dans cette situation ne
pas mettre le débat plat et ne pas se
dire au fond est ce que ça aurait l'air
faudrait relire le débat sur la
légalisation du cannabis et sur la
dépénalisation qui n'est pas la
légalisation je voulais répondre
là-dessus arrivant c'est à dire que la
légalisation moi je pense que c'est allé
trop loin
mais en revanche la dépénalisation était
d'ailleurs sur la table quand le
gouvernement
a été élu et ils ont choisi une solution
du en même temps qui consiste à mettre à
la fois une amende qui grosso modo les
gens vont se dire bah je mens je m'en
tire comme ça et en même temps la
pénalisation restera comme une menace
mais qui ne fonctionne pas donc on a
jamais eu une législation aussi
théorique et je rappelle qu'en france on
est un des pays d'europe où il ya le
plus de consommateurs de cannabis mais
très largement c'est extrêmement répandu
lorsque nous dînions sur youtube la
morne n'est pas le moyen le plus
efficace mais c'est un début après tout
la drogue est un produit légal
bon écoute et il pense comme il veut moi
je pense que le sujet c'est l'efficacité
des politiques publiques c'est à dire
que pouvoir dire en théorie c'est comme
ça et qu'on constate le contraire sur le
terrain c'est mauvais pour l'autorité de
l'état
mais pardonnez moi je vous fais une
objection l'uci parce qu'il ya quelque
chose d'illégal qui est très développé
on dit ben finalement on va on va soit
dépénalisé ou soit le rendre légale ont
fait l'état où les gouvernements font
plus rien non mais ce que je pense c'est
qu'il ya une solution de facilité par
rapport aux petits consommateurs c'est à
dire que les trafiquants c'est très
compliqué parce que ce sont des trafics
internationaux et ils trafic de la
drogue trafic d armes
là on voit bien qu'on se concentre sur
le cannabis parce que la cocaïne c'est
plus compliqué et que c'est des plus
gros trafiquants donc est-ce qu'il ya
pas là aussi quelque chose sur lequel le
ministre de l'intérieur devrait
s'interroger c'est à dire comment est ce
qu'on fait efficacement pour lutter
contre des trafiquants internationaux
qui ont beaucoup d'argent les meilleurs
avocats et qui se servent de petits
relais qui omet ne connaissent pas
l'ampleur du trafic c'est une mafia
en fait on le sait bien pons l'ancien
chef du service société dû finir mais je
crois que on se focalise sur les fm est
reçu comme toujours on en oublie les
causes se les est fait naturellement ils
ont été très bien décrit de la saison on
peut on peut en discuter de savoir ce
qu'il faut dépénaliser ou je ne sais
quoi cannabis mme mêlée ce sont les
causes qui sont essentiels et l'écossé
de savoir comment la lande et en arriver
là d'avoir deux france aujourd'hui
qu'ils se sont séparés avec deux france
qui n'ont pas les mêmes les mêmes
cultures les mêmes civilisation les
mêmes économies et singulièrement dans
une danse est france dans cette france
parallèle dans cette contre société et
une économie qui devient une économie
criminelle est alors naturellement on
peut simplement se focaliser sur le
cannabis mais le cannabis est simplement
un épiphénomène de ce que deux
le ski et plus profondément une rupture
fondamentale aujourd'hui au coeur de la
société est au coeur d'une nation qui
était une nation unie il encore pas si
longtemps je voulais lui dire un petit
mot sur grenoble
vous n'êtes que on vient de vivre un
événement où en fait on a eu un ministre
de l'intérieur et le maire de la ville
qui au fond ont vu des images d'une
vidéo qui est extrêmement violente avec
des trafiquants d'armes qui en fait des
dealers qui venaient devant des caméras
pour se vanter et on a découvert ensuite
c'était sans doute un clip de rap et on
voit bien que ça signifie que du côté
des grands hommes politiques c'est à
dire un ministre de l'intérieur un maire
de grenoble qui voudrait être candidat
pour les verts aux présidentielles il ya
ce décalage que vient de constater
vivant qui est au fond qu'il ya un
imaginaire terrible dans certaines cités
dans certains quartiers dire qu'on
montre les dealers on montre une contre
société violente mais c'est pris au
sérieux par le ministre l'intérieur
alors qu'il s'agit d'un clip de rap
moi je pense que ça c'est quelque chose
qui montre qu'il faut aller davantage
sur le terrain faire de la filtration
démente et les trafiquants ça prend du
temps mais ça signifie aussi ne pas
faire seulement des actions
d'interpellation devant les caméras vous
laisseriez entendre que ce que l'on a vu
qu'ils étaient un effet sans doute
fictif n'existe pas non plus il y a
quand même malgré tout de ces genres de
trafics il y à des trafics d'armes il ya
également cette cassure l'ostentation de
ces de ces armes à feu on l'avait vu par
exemple à blois
rappelez vous aimez commune la ghréline
qui avait brandi ses hommes contre la
commune et nos jeunes a déjà joué à
dijon par mais comme le disait vincent
ce qui est intéressant c'est que souvent
ça ne se voit pas quelque part plus
c'est pervers mais plus c'est bien
organisé - ça se voit et un acte de
provocation
je suis pas sûr que les vrais
trafiquants ils vont le faire alors je
leur ai dit mais la danse pour reprendre
cet exemple précis
peut-être que ce que la scène est
effective mais ce que lorsque cela met
en cause n'est pas tellement la réalité
de ce trafic c'est ce qui met en cause l
c'est la facilité c'est le le manque
d'esprit critique que nous avons tous
parce que les milliards sont ils tombés
dans le piège face aux réseaux sociaux
qui nous balance d'exact pages dont on
ne sait pas d'où elles viennent c'est
plus pour ça qu'ils seraient à discuter
à savoir et si vraiment on peut avoir on
peut aller à chaque fois la source des
images qui nous sont données et dieu
sait si on en est inondée
christophe est pas encore convaincu lui
que ce soit en montage ce qui n'est en
plus peut-être
h celui qui se prétend comme étant le
réalisateur du clip a été mis en garde à
vue aujourd'hui on en sera un petit peu
plus peut-être dans les heures ou dans
les jours qui viennent et en tout cas
c'est un débat qui est encore ouvert
l'amande de 200 euros en tout cas pour
consommation de drogue vous parait-elle
dissuasif c'est la question qui est
posée sur le site du figaro et pour la
plupart vous n'êtes pas convaincu
puisque d'après de 74%
vous répondez non vous pouvez encore
voter si vous l'avez pas encore fait
jusqu'à demain sur le site du figaro on
se retrouve demain même heure même
endroit merci beaucoup nous a reçus
merci beaucoup d'avoir des battus merci
vent merci lucide et on se retrouve très
vite sur le site du film